[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein norwegisches gebäck
nämlich schola mullah kuli paul's
colleges
kolle brot oder skoda will heißt und
zwar ist das auf süßes eine art teig
teilchen so plunder wie vom bäcker aus
hefeteig mit einer schönen vanillecreme
und kokos oben drauf das hat man damals
entwickelt um kindern was mit in die
schule oder als fest mitzugeben was man
eben gut aus der hand essen kann und ihr
wisst ich lieb' ich lebe vanillecreme
also ist es das perfekte gepäck für mich
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für den
hefeteig das ist im prinzip ein ganz
normaler standard hefeteig mit einer
besonderheit und zwar mit kardamon ich
dafür nämlich einen würfel hefe 80 gramm
zucker 2 esslöffel warmes wasser 500
gramm mehl da könnt ihr weizen oder
dinkelmehl verwenden ein einen teelöffel
salz etwa 230 milliliter milch 100 gramm
weiche butter und etwas kardamom und
beim karton nämlich einfach eine kapsel
ist ein richtig tolles gewürz kommt auch
in der indischen küche ganz oft vor ihr
könnt karte aber um auch schon gemahlen
kaufen aber ich find es tatsächlich
besser wenn er die karte um kapsel nimmt
dann könnt ihr nämlich diese hülle
drumherum weg machen und diese kardamom
samen darin raus lösen ich drücke das
mal kurz und dann habt ihr hier diese
kleinen samen da drin die nehme ich dann
nämlich und kann sie zerdrücken und bei
katar um den man kaufen kann gerade der
gemahlene da ist es nämlich so drücken
einfach immer alles und dann habt ihr
auch die schale mit dabei und dann ist
es eben nicht so ganz automatisch wie
wenn ihr jetzt nur das innere benutzt
also kommt das jetzt hier bei mir in den
mörser das wirklich eine ganz kleine
menge aber mal riecht schon direkt wie
gut es riecht man jetzt einfach kurz zu
drücken
[Musik]
und da kann ich jetzt hier die hefe
zerbröseln mit zucker und wasser
vermischen
[Musik]
und dann gebe ich die restlichen zutaten
dazu immer zuletzt das fett und das salz
also hier auch schon mal das eine
trial
jetzt salz drauf einfach schauen dass
salz und butter nicht direkt auf die
hefe kommen das ist dann immer nicht
ganz so gut für die hefe aber sie nicht
zum schluss darauf gibt dann passt
und ein bisschen kardamom
also da reicht auch wirklich so eine
prise soul
und am schönen heber teig verkneten etwa
zehn minuten lang mit dahin mit der hand
und mit den händen oder mit der kirche
maschine
jetzt ist der teig soweit und ihr könnt
immer mal schauen je nachdem welche
mails ort ihr verwendet ob jetzt dinkel
630 nehmt oder weizen 405 oder weizen
550 kann es sein dass ihr bis zu 50
gramm mehl braucht oder auch manchmal
ein bisschen weniger damit die
konsistenz dann einfach passt also
sollte jetzt einfach ein schöner weicher
teig sein der aber auch nicht mehr klebt
und er klebt einfach nicht mehr wenn ihr
ihn lange genug knetet und wenn ihr eben
auch genügend mail da drinnen habe ich
dann merke ich jetzt schon so ein
bisschen weich also ein bisschen mehr
knete ich dann noch kurz so ein
ich finde da merkt man das so am ende
noch mal ganz gut wie die konsistenz ist
und dann formte ihn schon zu einer kugel
lasst ihn dann in der schüssel abgedeckt
aufgehen und wenn er die kenwood habt
dann könnt ihr da gerne 34 grad
einstellen dann könnte es so aufgehen
lassen oder wenn in den dampf backofen
habe dann auch gerne bei der stufe 34
grad durch den dampf trocknet der tag
auch nicht aus da muss man nicht
abdecken in der kennwort hat man ja
einfach den spritzschutz und wenn ihr
gar nichts von beidem habe dann einfach
bei raumtemperatur aufgehen lassen schön
abdecken damit er nicht austrocknet
[Musik]
solange der teig aufgeht kann ich jetzt
schon mal den vanillepudding machen
dafür verwende ich 500 milliliter milch
3 eigelb 50 km strecke 100 gramm zucker
und etwas mandl extrakt ich muss auch
sagen dass ich pudding teilchen vom
bäcker schon sehr
erleben wir meist sonne kalt
aufgeschlagene vanillecreme die sie dann
auch mit backen und die ist einfach
lecker ich mag es gern und ich mag auch
rampf laden und ich mag berliner bei
denen wir jetzt übrigens mittlerweile
warum es die im sommer net gibt die gibt
es nur in wintermonaten nämlich da hat
haben wir nämlich ganz viele aus der
community feedback gegeben in der
backstube ist nämlich sowieso schon heiß
genug und wenn man dann noch anfängt zu
frittieren aber jetzt noch heißer und
das gepäck lässt sich wohl im sommer
nicht so gut lagern in der der
verkaufsfläche und deswegen gibt es
berliner in der kalten jahreszeit ja nun
eine art geschrieben weil es rasch ins
gepäck ist ein verschenktes aufgedreht
das war lustig ja jedenfalls machen
jetzt in vanillepudding der wert war
gerührt das heißt der wird gekocht
einfach kurz die milch in den topf geben
die stärke zum binden das eigelb auch
zum binden aber letztendlich doch mehr
für die farbe muss ich sagen und auch
für die cremigkeit und das kurz
verrühren und ich konnte kaum auskratzen
den
unausgewogen
jetzt könnte hier die stärke und das
eigelb schön klümpchen frei verrühren
und
dann einfach die restliche milch zu
gießen
habt ihr meine schleife schon bewährt
habe ich in verschiedenen farben
an seinem tod kommt das gut aufstellen
sagt da jetzt noch zucker dazu und
natürlich vanille extrakt da immer
darauf achten kurz vorher schütteln
bevor es verwendet und dann schon so ein
bis eineinhalb teelöffel damit ein
und schön rühren und ich schaltete den
herd nicht auf höchste stufe das sollte
sie ihr daheim auch nicht machen sonst
brennt euch der pudding unten am besten
auf mittel hohe stufe so auf sieben von
neun ist ganz gut und jetzt immer schön
rühren und währenddessen den pudding
aufkochen lassen
[Musik]
der pudding wirkt jetzt einmal aufkochen
das reicht dann auch schon jetzt kann es
natürlich sein dass ihr trotz
ordentlichen roms krempchen habt das
passiert auch den besten
und deswegen dem letzten sieg ein haar
sie ich habe jetzt hier meine fleißige
lieschen das fleißige lieschen das ist
die kleine schwester von der flotten
lotte
die flotte lotte kennt ihr natürlich
darf nochmal lade damit und apfelmus und
kompott und alles mögliche und die
flotte lotte die hat so große löcher und
das fleißige lieschen ist die kleine
schwester die so ganz fein und wenn man
eben pudding macht oder ganz feine dinge
dann könnt ihr das benutzen dann spart
man sich nämlich ganz viel arbeit
ich finde einfach den namen so süß
flotte lotte und fleißiges lieschen
flotte sally und fleißiges moretti
könnte man es auch machen wir benennen
sind warum also wäre schon ein kupfer
topf in der hand hat und er weiß dass
ich jedes mal wenn ich das so in der
hand habe schon krasses workout hinlegen
die sind echt schwer
verdammt schweren und jetzt einfach
schön drehen
[Musik]
so und jetzt einfach schön abdecken
abkühlen lassen und bis dahin ist der
teig dann auch aufgegangen dann geht es
gleich weiter
jetzt ist der hefeteig perfekt
aufgegangen
ich liebe hefeteig hab ich das mal
erwähnt
ich finde ihn einfach so der ist so
schön
kultur
und ich werde jetzt daraus denke ich 25
brötchen machen nieder wenn sie richtig
groß ich mach 16
16 klingt gut könnt ihr den teig einfach
nur vierteln und dann jedes viertel noch
mal vierteln oder ihr nehmt so ein taten
einteiler mit 16 stückchen
könnte das auch schön portionieren und
dann die portionen zu kleinen schönen
gleichmäßigen kugeln formen
[Musik]
man guckt mal nicht formt es dann immer
hier ganz gern zumal kugel
oder ihr nehmt sie in die hand und formt
dann praktisch von außen nach innen
so zusammen zucken und dann zu einer
kugel formen das geht auch
[Musik]
so sind es jetzt richtig schön die
werden kurz abgedeckt damit sie sich
entspannen können so etwa 10-15 minuten
und der pudding dass er auch gut
abgekühlt den rühre ich jetzt allerdings
noch mal gut deutsch damit er einfach
schön geschmeidig ist und ich ihn dann
gleich funktionieren kann
[Musik]
schön sind aus
ich denke mal nur die hälfte auf und
jetzt formt er hier in der mitte einfach
so eine kleine vertiefung
der rand da so schön dick bleiben und
voll schön gleichmäßig
das sieht gut aus dann kommen immer
acht stück auf ein blech
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier schon an die
öffnungen drin jetzt nehmt ihr euch ein
eigelb und einen esslöffel milch
verrührt das ganze und köln steht
teilchen damit bestreichen dann glänzen
so schön und werden schön braun im ofen
einfach schön einmal ringsrum
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich hier einen mittleren eis
portionierer ihr wisst ja bei mir ist
ein funktionieren eigentlich gar keines
portionierer sondern eher an alles
portionierer den kleinen nämlich immer
gerne wenn ich zum beispiel so kleine
kügelchen kugel energy corp was mache
ich dann auch gerne kleine frikadellen
den mittleren nehme ich jetzt hier für
und kann auch damit frikadellen formen
linsen welchen oder auch andere tolle
gerichte und der große passt perfekt um
muffins zu portionieren und das ist dann
immer ganz cool weil man so eben nicht
so lang gebraucht heißt hier einfach
einen löffel voll
und doug reinsetzen
[Musik]
ich drückte jetzt sind bisher mit einer
palette noch flach
und ich habe den ofen nicht vorgeheizt
das erste blech ihr seht ihr auch das
zweite liegt hier noch brav das erste
blech kommt in den kalten backofen dann
schalte ich den ofen an und während der
ofen aufheizt gehen die teilchen nämlich
im ofen schön auf das zweite blech
bereit ich in der zwischenzeit zu und
denkst dann einfach ab dann können die
sonne aufgehen und die packe ich dann
gleich im heißen ofen so spart man sich
immer so ein bisschen zeit bei der
zubereitung weil ich will jetzt auch
nicht bei umluft backen sondern wirklich
bei ober unterhitze damit es geht weg
nicht austrocknet und schöne bräune
bekommt
[Musik]
für uns nur beachten das erste blech im
kalten ofen das packt ein bisschen
länger als das zweite
[Musik]
ich bin sehr glücklich weil es so schön
aussieht kann ich das mal an die sind so
perfekt aber um sie jetzt noch
fertigzustellen kaum noch was drauf und
zwar eine puderzucker zitronengras und
kokosraspeln wenn ihr das nicht mögt
lass das weg aber im original gehört
auch so deswegen habe ich jetzt hier
schon 100 gramm puderzucker da kommt
jetzt etwas zitronensaft dazu
[Musik]
nicht zu viel
ganz schön verrühren
warum er
hat nicht gereicht aber
jetzt möchte ich muss mal wieder
zitronenkuchen backen den richtig
klassischen blechkuchen ja
[Musik]
jetzt nehmt ihr euch immer so ein
teilchen und dann einfach nur am rand
bestreichen hier
und da die kokosraspeln dran kleben
was soll schon noch diese schöne bräune
sehen finde ich
nicht so viel
ich finde es können ostergebäck sein
gehör mutter sagt ich finde auch dass
könnten rohstoffe wechseln
[Musik]
die gäste nahmen
scott ok
wat ich sag was nieder was wartet
bug des college hill deck
dich merkwürdig
war danach danke jutta
paktes kohle pro tell data kalt
sollte
tax kalt doch
das einzige was nur mit euch
mitnehmen
[Gelächter]
man vertraut nicht vieles kann außer
wenn die kokosflocken bisher ja sie
jetzt autor wie
yahoo krieg um mit probieren ja
genau ich hab ihnen mitteile 1 aber dann
hab ich noch nicht
[Gelächter]
ich liebe solche dinge
ohne schnickschnack große
einfach und einfach lecker und
luftig und
was toll ist dass häfen der hefeteig
dann so die creme und dann die säure
aber was die nicht schmecken das ließ
das gewürz hoch
das schmeckt man aber ich probiere mal
nur das
vergessen war scheint durch die
kokosflocken die übertönen dessen
ich glaube man kann die ganze karte um
kapseln immer ich habe nur so eine prise
nein aber ich wünsche ihr solltet alles
nehme weil damals meine hausboot auf
jeden fall also ich sehr zurückhaltend
er hat sich schwenk gebacken und es
sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein
ostergebäck also in ein paar wochen
können also ganz so stand zu bereiten
dann könnte das sogar den pudding aus
eiliger kochen
[Gelächter]
ist man ja daraufhin forderte zum kaffee
oder effekt war ich finde es ist ein
hammer rezept also probiert das gerne
mal aus ihr findet die ihre zutaten auf
cds - dot de oder in meiner app da könnt
ihr das rezept organ verdoppeln und
verdreifachen und direkt eine große
menge zu bereiten und falls ihr weiteres
gepäck aus verschiedenen ländern kennt
was wir unbedingt mal ausprobieren
sollten mutter und ich will lernen dann
und machen daher gerne in die kommentare
aber machen wir das beim nächsten und
sprachbegabt
neuen slate regelt das wären
also fahren wir nach machen bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]
richtig gut